hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game another game from the super
rapid and blitz tournament again we have
untold horrible this time he faces shock
here mamedyarov
after three days of rapid it is Anton
horrible who is leading the tournament
and this is a a game from round 8 of the
blade section so this is a blitz game
and well it's just a very impressive
game so I do hope you enjoy it without
further ado let's just check it out
mommy Gareth with the white pieces opens
with c4 sorry about that
we have E 6 and now comes d4 so
basically we're just transposing into
the Queens gambit declined beat the 5 9
f3 Knight to f6 and Bishop to g5 we have
c6
reinforcing the center and now III by
Mahmoud er we have Knight B to d7 9th to
c3 and h6 and like I said Mahmud
horrible leading the tournament after
round 1 but he's still leading the
tournament after three days of rapid and
after eight eight rounds of blitz even
though he hadn't really played all that
well in blitz he lost two games and all
the other games were drawn but still you
know because the other players gain
again one point for a win you don't get
to catch up so quickly because well it's
blitz a rapid just the points better so
let's go back to h4 with g5 bike or
above and Bishop to g3 Knight to e5
going after the darks worship Queen to
c2 end here the bishop is just
eliminated Knight captures aged captures
and the Bishop to g7 so horrible will
try to create chances in this game using
his bishop repair if of course the game
allows and if shock allows we have a
queenside castle by Mahmud Europe and
here are a lot of moves that have been
played Queen to e7 is a norm of a 6 mm
all night and well nice the b6 is a non
move Queen to a5 is a no move just going
well pressuring the a to pawn but here
we have castles by core above and it is
a new move in the position which you can
imagine not a lot of people will castle
here or the H file is the semi open file
already the Queen
is attacking the king said the bishop
can very easily join the rooks can be
easily doubled on the h-file so it is
for good reason that no one before core
above castles in this position but okay
King b1 always a useful move maybe even
king day one as Corvo still has two
bishops so maybe you don't want your
king and queen on on the same diagonal
but okay Queen to e7 bike or above
preparing to maybe push e5 and now II
for my mom er with D captures Knight
captures and now f5 a wonderful
expansion on the Kings side although
when you have a castle King on the on
the Kings side you you basically don't
want to advance the pawns in front of
your own King but Cora buff doesn't mind
Knight back to c3 and now even c5
challenging the center mom video of
advances the pawn we have d5 and now
Knight to f6 horrible doesn't care about
anything here we have nice thief I've
mom your could also put d6 advancing the
point creating a very strong pass pawn
on d6 but it's a blitz game and you
don't you've never had this position you
don't know if it will be a very strong
passed pawn or maybe it's gonna be a
liability will you be able to defend it
so before deciding on whether to pull
these six marble goes 95 he says okay
deal with Knight g6 it's a threat I'm
gonna win material here but horrible
doesn't care just eat capture son b5 he
says okay you can have it on IG 6 I'm
gonna advance this pawn to d4 and create
a passed pawn for the sacrificed
exchange so Knight g6 attacking the
Queen and the rook Queen f7 and now
Knight captures on f8 and not before
automatically capturing you should
always be careful not to recap for
something automatically first a nice
efficient tube d4
this night can cannot escape so it's not
a problem with Knight to d5 and now just
Queen captures on f8 Bishop to d3 Mahmud
continuous development DF 5 pawn is now
under attack and now Knight captures on
d5 which also allows the Queen and
Bishop to keep an eye on the f5 pawn so
the seek after Sun d5 and Bishop to d7
with Bishop to d7
coral buff prepares to bring the rook
into the game but more importantly he
prepares to advance the pawns on the
Queen side so b5 is coming and here mama
DRO
probably play a four regardless of the
fact that maybe perhaps b5 is not the
greatest move but it's blitz you don't
want to see be b5 and and c4 on the
board Mammadov it doesn't think it's
it's worth stopping so f4 preparing to
open lines on the kingside and b5 now
Corbeau is preparing to push all his
pawns on the queenside as mom your skin
is castled on the King side Queen side
we have capture son g5 and now see for
advancing even further and here G
captures on h6 mom your calculate
precisely that this is this is a good
move problem with C captors on d3 I know
you guys are checking this audio you
guys are like oh that's that's a nice
nice idea well not really because of
Queen to c7 and you don't gain anything
white will easily regain a piece here so
once you do something you can just trade
here capture here and you're still up
the exchange you're gonna win this point
you're gonna win this one and it's just
gonna be a winning game for white so
after G captors and h6 with Bishop to e5
getting the bishop out of harm's way and
now you don't really have a way of
moving your bishop if you if you move
with the d3 is coming so yeah I mean you
could maybe move it to f1 but mama D ro
is not the kind of guy that but you know
moves the bishop all the way to f1 in
between the ropes so it's just not
that's not how you play chess so he
boldly advances the g4 pawn and
sacrifices the bishop on d3 okay quarter
both captures C captures we have Queen
captures on d3 and now mama D off should
sort of horrible should probably go for
Queen f7 try to snap off the d5 pawn
maybe get the rook into the game and see
how it goes but core both decides that
the g4 pawn is too important to just let
you know
roam freely so he plays Punk a person g4
and now rook dita f1 my media of now
unleashes a full attack on Cora both the
Queen is under attack we have Queen to
d6 going after the d5 pawn but now rook
to h5 saying okay
what are you going to do here and now
it's it's a really a tough position to
be in for example if you try something
like rook to f8 then look the g5 check
is coming King to h8 and now rook to f7
will just be sorry not rook to f7 roof
to f7 will be just a well terrible idea
not even sure why I have rook to f7 here
it's I meant to rook captures on f8
obviously that's really really weird why
I just did that but yeah I have to
recapture screen captures you can just
play route chapter 75 so it's not a
problem you don't have any any tricks
here Queen to f1 is guarded so you can't
even do any anything to prevent a wife
from just winning this
so after rook to h5 we have looked eight
instead and now rook the g5 with check
with King the h8 and now rook to f7
probably why I thought it was a roof to
f7 in that line it was really weird
well yeah Luke to have seven and here
just Queen to h7 the threat of mate is
it's just ugly there's only one move
that save score bovis Queen captures on
age sex it doesn't save Korra go for
very long we look out for Sun b7 just
winning back the PCs used to can't
capture here because of mate
so after Luke characters and e7 with
Bishop f6 by quarter both and now it's
Mahmoud off to move feel free to pause
the game the video and find the winning
idea from my media of while I give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations as no
one can find this this is a you know
this is impossible to find in a Belize
game especially we're here Madera is
under a minute on the clock but it's
route captures on g4 and it's just
insane why this is the only winning move
let me just explain for a bit before
this move for example after rook to e8
sorry after the shop to f6 if you try
rook g6 probably you had this in mind it
will only yield a draw because rook to
e1 check King has to move and now Queen
the c1 with check King to b3 and now you
get looked at
sort of winning a queen but not really
because of Luke h6 check and now it's a
perpetual king GA to Ruby six check you
to go back and accept a perpetual or you
go here check you go here and then this
check save the queen
so King captures you're gonna capture
here pawn captures and after this let's
say Queen captures on b5 with the check
White's queen is more active and it
already starts with check but it's not
enough as black spawn is already on e3
so this this game I would unwind in a
draw the reason why after Bishop to have
six rook captures energy for is the only
good move because now after rook to e1
check King to see to what do you play
here now you don't really gain anything
by Queen to c1 the problem is after the
rook is now on g4 so after you will not
have to worry about a perpetual for
example if Queen to c1 check here and
King to b3 the same ideas no longer
apply rook to e3 what do you do here
just look to h7 and that's now made so
that's the difference really just a
wonderful stuff so after King to c2 best
for black would be to just go to go not
rook to e3
well yes rook to e3 kinda immediately
going after the Queen but now rook to e4
and that's the point and who among you
would be able to find this with under a
minute on the clock I mean let's just
check that out again
so after Bishop f6 rook captures n g4
rook e1 check King to see two rookie
three and now you are lost if you don't
find anything if you move the Queen even
this check becomes possible but now now
you find rook to e4 and that's just not
something you find all over the board in
a blitz game point being if rook
captures this is now mate after Queen a
faith now now mama yard gets the
checkmate horrible but after Bishop f6
of course mama did not find rook
captures and reform no one finds rook
captures on g4 and why in fact is it
different and why it doesn't allow rook
to eat one for the Queen to see one and
I was actually I was very well I didn't
enjoy that in the official
broadcast that they called mama Della's
move a blunder yes if you put this
position in in an engine it will tell
you that
mama dear is completely winning and
after my MIDI remove mommy there are
played Queen to g6 now mama Yahoo is
completely lost and of course if you go
from completely winning to completely
lost
it's the the basically the that
basically the definition of that move is
a blunder but here I I don't think this
can be called a blunder because who can
calculate route characters and g4 and
why it works it's just it's just not
possible so here Cora Bob is able was
able to trick mommy DRF into playing
Queen gg6 it seems like it's enough
because and of course if ma media of
thought that perhaps this wasn't enough
then maybe he would find group g4 but
here for example if Queen captures Queen
then okay it's just a winning endgame
rock and rock against rook and Bishop
and of course if you try Bishop
characters on g5 then you get Queen
captures on e8 and again this ends in
checkmate so this is what the mommies
are have had in mind but of course
horrible went for Queen to h1 check King
to see - and now not rook c8 rook c8 is
fine Queen characters and g2 is also
fine but immediately goes d3 check as
anyone would is just unleashes this
powerful bishop so Queen captures and d3
Mammadov brings the Queen back into the
defense but now Queen captures and g2
King D 1 now Queen g1 check King to see
- and now Queen to have to check and it
was in this position unmoved 37 that
chartres mom resigned the game and Anton
horrible still leads the tournament
after three full days of rapid and after
eight runs of late there's one more
round of wits left so I don't know how
he played in that game but yeah here he
results because you cannot go back due
to rook e1 rook e1 is just made and if
you don't if you try running away with
the King let's say King to b3 then Queen
captures on b2 is made so that's a
different rate and also if you try
blocking then it's just a few checks the
rook c8 check you're gonna move the king
you have to keep an eye on your Queen
Queen f1 check Queen blocks now you go
Queen B one check you cannot block as a
row covers the c2 square you're gonna
move
now finally rukia check wins the queen
so really just an impressive game and
it's it's very rare that you will have
this position this is the position I'm
really fascinated with that it's the
engine says this it's the black is just
destroyed and but but who can find this
idea of root chakras energy for its just
a really really an elusive idea but yeah
that's that's the game I wanted to show
you and I do hope you enjoyed it to see
what what tricky guy this intone core
oboe is and you know if he can trick
mommy jar like this then he definitely
deserves to be leading the tournament
even though he's a wild card and I
wasn't a fair aware of the fact even
though he's the lowest rated player here
among the Giants here he's a wild card
but he has the highest rating when it
comes to rapid so it's basically no
wonder that he wonder the rapid section
I was the wear of that so thank you
everyone who you know reminded me of
that in the comments but yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank al from rota for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it and for your
message the messages happy birthday Mick
how tall as today's falls birthday so I
thought about showing at our game today
but as we are you know creeping up on
that 500,000 subscribers milestone where
we're gonna have a really awesome time
tall game I hope that you know mmm it's
not that too tall games are enough but
as there are so many things to cover now
we will always be able to show more tall
games so once again I do hope you
enjoyed it
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day